m
comme chaque année le collège chemin
morin à saint-andré a organisé son cross
une journée ludique et festif pour les
élèves ils étaient plus de 800 jeunes a
participé aux différentes courses
donc le cross est une institution au
niveau du collège ça fait depuis que le
collège est ouvert qu'on le cross a lieu
en début d'année en général c'est un pur
un petit peu permettre d'évaluer les
progrès qu'ont fait nos élèves notamment
dans les pratiques qu'ils ont avec nous
en demi fond on sait et puis c'est une
réelle manifestation qui rassemble tous
collèges
mais déjà le fait de voir qu'un collège
bouge les élèves sont vraiment aux
demandes de toutes ces manifestations
ça leur permet de voir le collège
autrement que simplement qu'un lieu de
travail un petit peu comme toutes les
activités qu'on fait l'association
sportive comme toutes les activités
qu'il ya dans le cadre du foyer
socio-éducatif aussi club de journalisme
aux chorales théâtre et toutes les
activités sportives comme le disais on
fait de la danse ont participé à des
championnats donc c'est voir le collège
autrement que simplement par le biais de
la classe
et comme le fait de s'asseoir devant un
tableau le collège un mort a fait le
choix d'intégrer les élèves de cm2 de
l'école primaire à ce cross l'occasion
de préparer ces jeunes à faire leur
rentrée un season de se familiariser
avec leur prochain établissement
et bien c'est les parties en fait de la
liaison primaire un soleil si ça ça
démystifie un peu le l'entrée en 6e ça
leur permet d'être mieux intégrés toît
et puis dans le réseau aujourd'hui on en
prolongement pour l'année prochaine la
réforme en grand dans le nez des
nouveaux cycles donc le cycle 3 intègre
le cm2 6e pensant donc ils sont déjà
dans cette dynamique là vraiment c'est
dans la continuité des apprentissages et
pour eux c'est quand ils vont revenir
ici l'année prochaine pour les cm2 ils
sont déjà dans un environnement connu le
vix premiers coureurs de chaque circuit
seront sélectionnés pour participer au
cross de district et ainsi représenter
leur collège